right this is a Game of Thrones video so
if you're not caught up on Game of
Thrones don't watch this heavy spoilers
here don't do that to yourself
we're talking if you are not through
season 4 episode 2 don't watch this
video unless you really don't care in
which case why don't you care cuz Game
of Thrones is pretty rad right if you're
still sticking around it means you're
caught up in which case I can tell you
guys guys I finally happen to be honest
with you guys I was gonna do a review on
draft day today but then Game of Thrones
happened I was like I guess we should
talk about that [ __ ] that's right
sometimes events happen that we just
have to sidetrack you know what I got to
do this one right now not have any on
this because george RR martin has
sequentially just he just picks people
off it's just the dead dead dead has
broken more hearts than John Stamos
himself and for different reasons but
still but now today he gave a little
back that's right folks we finally got
to see Jaime Lannister himself training
with Bronn how to fight with sword
southpaw and [ __ ] no there's not what
you wanted me to talk about what would
you want me to talk about what else
happened in this holy [ __ ] that's right
the dick died I don't mean Theon's dick
I mean like the dick dick I was Chucky
kid on Christmas when it was happening
to because it happens of course at a
wedding people are hash tagging purple
wedding which is a [ __ ] spoiler don't
do that [ __ ] anyone who hasn't seen the
episode sees purple wedding they're
gonna be like ad Jeffrey's dead Sciences
people were calling it the porthole [ __ ]
I'm wearing purple that actually was not
intentional I saw that my camera just
now and I was like oh don't drink the
wine but they totally play up in this
episode Joffrey is such a dick and
you're like when is this [ __ ] gonna
die for three seasons and two episodes
now we've all been saying that everybody
it's so uncomfortable in this wedding
and Joffrey's the only one laughing and
the sonses like you're a dick just
thinking of her brother and Tyrians like
my nephew's a dick Joffrey's wife's like
my husband's a dick seriously Elena's
just like oh my son's a day he's giving
his speeches like it and you know
another thing um after the second cop I
was just like at is it happening I was
like a kid on Christmas I was like okay
it's not even good boys not even like
upper-class sophisticated nice poison
obviously his wine was poisoned that or
the Heisenberg came by with his rice and
like later dick my chefs still cooler
I'd gameofthrones
but it's not the nice milk of the poppy
[ __ ] we're like are you going to his
sleep and then you just dream forever
no there's kids like gargling and
vomiting and foaming into like bloodshot
eyes and varicose veins he looks like a
really bad scene in the walking dead
bleeding out of his eyes and nose and
you're like oh honey good times yeah it
not to me honestly it wasn't enough I
wanted to see Joffrey get like the theon
greyjoy treatment I wanted to see
Joffrey get worse than anyone in the
show has gotten honestly I don't think
you did then again nothing was good bad
enough but the story is smart it would
only ever be poison it's the only way
you can kill a king and maybe get away
with it which begs the question who did
it which is very cool it's kind of a
mystery I need that because someone this
is like two weeks ago and I just looked
at there's only one kid ever like what
he's talking about bran Stark he doesn't
want him to die I don't like spoilers
that was all I know I knew I'm like I
can't unknown fact Joffrey's gonna die
luckily I thought I was gonna have to
wait all season for it it happened in
two episodes so now that spoiler I had
is gone it was beautiful that the
bleeding the hemorrhaging the coughing
died Joffrey just died but everyone at
this wedding and in Joffrey's life hated
his guts and a few people had the means
to kill him today notice like when the
cup drops Sansa Stark picked it up did
she poison it did Tyrion poison it how
did anyone know that he was gonna spill
his drink and then it would have time to
poison it was it his wife obviously
remember when she was talking to Baelish
I believe it was season two and she was
like I want it all so I always knew she
wanted to marry him to get the throne
who did it don't tell me don't be a dick
about it I'm just you know in my
monologue is going who did it don't want
the answer when his guys Joffrey died
and I'm glad the [ __ ] is dead kind
of I'm going to give a special thank you
to the actor who played Joffrey
Baratheon for all these years Jack lees
and Jack Gleeson
you killed it as Joffrey Baratheon you
made one of the most memorable
douchebags in sin I would say cinematic
history television history entertainment
history you portrayed him so well
everyone on earth who watch the show
loved to hate you and it is honestly not
going to be the same kind of ride
without you you are a kick-ass actor and
I hope people don't hate you in real
life for your portrayal of a really
memorable character
so guys Joffrey Baratheon dead what do
you feel about that if you say I you
know I liked him he was my favorite like
in
aspire to be like why the FBI just
flagged your computer you should
probably burn it and run whatever you
thought about this episode comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here you want to see
more click right here to see more